Hi everyone, Sal Khan here.
Welcome to "Homeroom with Sal."
We have a very exciting show today
after a bit of a hiatus,
we haven't done a live
stream in a little while,
but we have Vas Narasimhan
who is the CEO of Novartis.
We had him on last year at the
early phases of the pandemic.
And so you can imagine there's
a lot to talk about there,
but also just generally
about medical science
and running a large
multinational organization.
So if you have questions,
start thinking of them,
put them in the message
boards on Facebook or YouTube
or wherever you happen to be
watching this live stream.
Before we jump into it with Vas,
I will make my standard announcements.
First of all,
I want to remind everyone
we are a not for profit.
We can only exist with
philanthropic donations.
So if you are in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate
and donations of all size,
make a big, big difference
for our mission of trying
to educate the world.
I also want to make a special shout out
to a whole series of
organizations that stepped up
when they realized that
Kahn Academy's expenses
only went up when the world
started to depend on it
even more during the
global school closure.
So special thanks to
Bank of America, AT&T,
Google.org, Novartis,
Fastly, and General Motors.
And then last but not least,
I want to remind folks that
there is a podcast version
of this live stream, "Homeroom
with Sal, The Podcast,"
wherever you get your podcasts.
So with that, I am super
excited to welcome back
Vas Narasimhan back to our live stream.
And, you know, in full disclosure,
y'all are one of our
sponsors so thank you also.
And people should also
know I'm somewhat biased
towards you and Novartis (laughs)
so take everything we say
with a grain of salt.
But welcome back Vas.
- Great to be here, Sal,
and I've even put on a,
my kids gave me a Kahn Academy sticker
to really be a part of the cause,
so we're thrilled to support Kahn Academy.
I think it's amazing what all of you do.
I look forward to the discussions.
- You know, I'm both
heartened and disappointed
by what you just said.
I'm heartened that you're
wearing a Kahn Academy sticker.
I'm disappointed that
your kids had to force you
to wear that.
I'd like to think that in
your day-to-day management
of running one of the largest
pharma companies in the world,
you wear a Kahn Academy sticker
but maybe that will change.
- I'll take that on advisement, Sal.
I'll take it on advisement.
- Well, you know, maybe
a good place to start
and actually I have a
question, obviously we're in,
I guess, I don't know what
we'd call it, year two now
of COVID-19 some people are saying
it should be called COVID 20
now with the Delta variant,
and I've heard this word syndemic,
and I'm hearing it actually
in, kind of pharma,
medical circles.
My wife's a doctor as well.
What is a syndemic?
- A syndemic is the term we use kind of
for a parallel epidemic that's happening
alongside the pandemic.
I mean, what we saw throughout last year,
because unfortunately, as COVID took hold
across healthcare systems,
if patients didn't get
the routine care they need
for things like cancer,
cardiovascular disease, lung disease,
a range of different diseases.
Part of that were
patients were afraid to go
to the hospital.
A big part of that were
hospitals were just so busy
caring for COVID patients.
And what that leads to is
when patients aren't getting
their normal care for
noncommunicable diseases
like heart disease or cancer,
those diseases get worse.
And actually it's even harder
to treat those patients
later on.
Now we saw that improve in
the first part of this year,
as it looked like things
were getting better.
Unfortunately now, as Delta
variant takes hold again,
we're seeing it again be an issue.
I'm hopeful that healthcare
systems can figure out
a way to continue to see patients,
so they get the care they need.
- Yeah, I mean, it's a
fascinating question,
because we've talked a
lot about school closures
and learning loss, and
it's one of these things
where we as human beings,
we'll obviously watch the news
and we'll see people who
are getting hospitalized
and intubated or worse
because of the pandemic.
So that feels very urgent.
And then a lot of what we
try to do at Kahn Academy is
remind folks, well,
there's also side effects
of kids not being in school.
In fact, long-term, there could
be even larger side effects,
more harm to more kids than
even the pandemic itself.
And what you're bringing up is
even though our healthcare
system is operating
and doing incredible things
when the pandemic picks up
and especially once ICUs
fill up or people are afraid
to go to the hospital,
it's creating a bit of
a health loss, a health debt,
which my wife has also described.
Like she just started, now
that she's seeing more patients
in person, she's seeing how much,
how many of her patients
have really degraded
in the time that they were afraid
or they couldn't come to the hospital.
How does Novartis,
you know, before we started recording,
I actually didn't fully appreciate,
a lot of people when they
talk about the vaccines,
they're talking about
Pfizer, Moderna, and J&J,
but I didn't realize
that y'all were actually
one of the larger producers of vaccines,
but above and beyond, I'm
curious how that's been going,
but above and beyond that,
when you're running a large,
one of the largest pharma
companies in the world,
I believe the largest
producer of pharmaceuticals,
you know, what is the
pandemic or the syndemic,
has that changed what y'all are doing?
And does it change how you
think about what your goal is
as an organization?
- It's had a lot of different impacts.
Just to give your
listeners a sense of scope,
I mean, so we are about 110,000 people,
operate in 150 countries.
We produce about 70 billion
doses of medicine a year,
and in a usual year, we reach
about 800 million patients
with those medicines.
So a very, very large, large scale.
Now, of course, when you have
something like this disrupt
healthcare systems it
impacts our business,
also impacts our ability
to run clinical trials.
Many of our clinical
trials were disrupted.
We've had to do a lot of
work to keep clinical trials
and clinical research going
at an appropriate pace.
One of the other challenges that we see
from a clinical standpoint is,
I'm sure your wife is seeing this as well.
If you see cancer patients
who are treated later,
usually the medicines have
a harder and harder time
having their effect if
patients are more progressed,
similarly in heart
disease or lung disease.
So we're trying to educate policy makers.
I think health ministers
that I speak with are
very aware of this challenge,
but it is a very human challenge.
In the end, people can
get very afraid to go
to the hospital and they
put off routine care
or very routine screening
in the case of many
of these diseases.
And you also asked about
vaccine production.
I mean, our part I think is small
relative to many of the companies
that are the innovators of these vaccines,
but given our very large
manufacturing footprint,
we are able to produce
vaccines here in Switzerland
and our facilities in Austria,
to support, you know, the global pandemic.
And it's something that
I think we feel like is
part of our responsibility as
a large healthcare company.
- And I never thought about
it, I mean we were talking
about the syndemic just now
and how other types of things
could be slowed down, or
there could be a health debt,
but I never thought about the impact
on clinical trials themselves.
Do you think industry-wide
this is actually slowing down
some drugs that could have
gone to market sooner?
- I mean, I think it remains to be seen.
I mean, companies have
been working really hard.
Like for instance, one of the
big transitions we've seen is
just to use technology to keep
people on clinical trials.
So clinical trials used to be
a very human-heavy endeavor,
and now we're using remote monitoring
to monitor the patients
on our clinical trials,
keep them on study.
But I do think you'll see
some impacts for sure.
I mean, if you're just
thinking about the disruption,
a clinical trial anyway is
such a hard thing to run.
If suddenly like an entire country says,
no patients can come into the hospital
and then suddenly that
country is shut down
for your clinical trial.
Then you have to go to another country.
These create disruptions in your datasets.
And then when you run the statistics,
statistics that many people learn about
through Khan Academy,
those statistics get harder
to run because you have to
account for all of these
disruptions that have
happened in the studies.
I would say though overall,
at least we've been able
to manage reasonably well.
- Yeah, no, no.
It's fascinating.
And I will, as an aside,
give you full credit.
You are the best guest
when it comes to plugging Khan Academy.
Beyond the sticker on your shirt,
if you mention statistics,
you remind everyone
it can be learned on Kahn Academy.
So... (laughing)
- You know, my son just
completed the statistics course
on Kahn Academy.
So that's why I knew about the statistics.
I was getting my own refresher
on some of these topics.
- I think I'm going to send
you another sticker, Vas.
You deserve it.
(Vas laughs)
- Well, I mean,
getting to more serious topics,
which I unfortunately
took us on a tangent,
the vaccine itself, you know, thank God.
Thank the universe that we now have them.
Obviously it's somewhat been politicized
where not everyone is taking them,
but what's your view of how
this is going to play out?
You know, I remember
last year I was watching
some news channel and there
was some epidemiologist
who seemed like doom and gloom.
Who's like, "This thing's
always going to be here.
It's gonna be like the flu.
It's gonna be constantly evolving.
We're just gonna have to live
with COVID in the future."
And I remember at the
time, everyone, I think,
thought that guy was a wet blanket.
Like it's not going to be that way.
Now it's starting to feel like
that guy might've been right.
Obviously you have the Delta variant,
people are talking about booster shots.
People are talking about, do
we need a Delta aware vaccine?
What's your view of all of this?
Are people working on
a Delta aware vaccine?
Is this going to constantly evolve?
Will there be a, you know,
a gamma, and an omega,
a COVID 21?
How do you think this is going to happen?
- Yeah, so a few big principle points
I think it's worth for the
listeners to understand.
I mean, one we're surrounded by viruses.
I mean, if you think of a cup of seawater,
you have billions or trillions of viruses.
And viruses actually probably enabled
the first prokaryotic
and eukaryotic cells,
maybe even multicellular life.
So we live with viruses.
And then when you look at Corona viruses,
there are four normally
circulating Corona viruses
that cause the common cold,
alongside many other
viruses that we deal with
as the human species and
that we've adapted to.
So usually with these types
of respiratory viruses,
the expectation is
eventually we will reach
an equilibrium state
where the virus evolves
to a place where it is causing
minimally symptomatic
disease, but enabling spread.
Think about the common cold,
runny nose, all those things.
And our immune systems get primed enough
that we can handle that
assault, because we have memory
in our T-cells, we also
have memory in our B cells
and we're able to deal with like, as we do
with other Corona viruses.
What we're observing right
now is that process happening.
And the virus is mutating.
Our immune systems are developing.
Vaccines are hopefully
enabling our immune systems
to get stronger.
They clearly are, and then
are enabling us to adapt.
And the question is how
can we as a global society
best manage that to minimize the impact
as we get to that equilibrium?
So that's kind of the way I
think about the big picture.
It's hard to know when exactly
that equilibrium will happen,
but it will.
But I think it's reasonable to expect
that this Corona virus will become
a normal circulating Corona virus.
like we have other Corona viruses
and cause symptomatic respiratory illness,
but probably nothing severe
because we have adapted to it
as a species.
Now, in the meantime, the question is
how much do we need to keep
working on future vaccines?
And I think it's an open question.
I think we have to be driven by data.
The data would seem to suggest
that the current vaccines produce
a very robust memory response.
It also seems naturally
infected people are producing
a memory response.
That's why we see less severe disease
and less hospitalizations and deaths
in people who are previously vaccinated,
but people who are previously
vaccinated are able
to get infected and spread.
And so we're gonna have to see,
I think in the coming months,
how the data plays out,
how the booster shots really
look from a data standpoint.
And I think the health
authorities then will figure out
what the right right path forward is.
But I think it's worth remembering
that this is going to be an equilibrium
that happens over time.
Also, I think it's an
incredible accomplishment
of modern science that
by the end of this year,
my guess is, we'll have
over 10 billion doses
of vaccine produced.
Which is really less than
18, 20 months from when
we first characterized this virus.
That's an astonishing
scientific achievement.
- No, it is incredible.
And you know,
just following on this notion
that vaccines are constantly evolving.
I mean, actually, I redid a
Kahn Academy video yesterday
about evolution and natural selection.
And I know sometimes people say,
"Oh, well this goes over,"
Or you know, "Something that
you don't necessarily see,
it occurs over millions of years."
I'm like, "No, you're
seeing it before your eyes"
with these variants of these viruses.
And you're seeing it every
year with the flu virus.
Evolution is happening.
And to your point, selection
pressure for a virus,
it wouldn't naturally select for viruses
that are necessarily more deadly.
It's actually not in the virus's
interest to kill the host.
Now I think everyone's
nightmare scenarios are
something that spreads like Delta,
you know, it's very easy to spread,
it can kind of evade at
least the first phases
of the immune system,
and then kind of stays
dormant while it spreads
and then becomes worse
and then becomes deadly.
Is it just kind of dark
science fiction thinking
that we could go in that direction?
Because, I guess the argument is
evolution wouldn't select
for something like that.
It could randomly happen because we have
so many hosts right now, billions of hosts
each with billions of viruses in them,
that is maybe accelerating
the evolution to some degree.
- Yeah, I think it's, I
mean, certainly all possible,
but in general, what we do observe,
and viruses, again, if you
look at parainfluenza viruses
and rhinoviruses and other Corona viruses,
the tropism and the way
they tend to evolve is
to be minimally symptomatic,
and very transmissible
because they actually want you
to move around and behave normally,
because that's how the gene,
as you likely taught in the
natural selection class,
will then pass on to the next generation
and the viruses will propagate.
If you look at other examples, things like
some of the hemorrhagic fevers
that come out of Africa,
whether it's Ebola, Marburg, Lassa,
they have very high case fatality rates,
but they usually burn out,
because eventually they
kill the host so fast
that transmission doesn't happen
and those tend to be very contained.
So that is what the history would tell us
and how you would expect
for this to play out.
I think even if you had a very,
you know, more virulent strain, again,
the human immune system is designed to,
especially for these kinds
of respiratory viruses,
to develop a very robust immune response.
But what you invariably have
when you have that happen,
is you will have a bump in severe cases
when such a virus comes about.
But I overall, Sal, remain optimistic.
I mean, when I look at these
kinds of respiratory viruses
and how in a big picture view,
how they tend to settle in,
in human populations,
they tend to trend towards
an equilibrium state
of minimally symptomatic
or mildly symptomatic,
cold-like respiratory condition.
Then we wouldn't even notice.
And we would just say,
"Oh, it's just another
circulating cold virus."
- Right, and we have
historical examples of that.
The flu, obviously at one point,
the flu was scary, very scary.
It's still not completely not scary,
but it's much more maintainable.
A big question, and it connects with
what we often talk about, education,
is vaccines for younger people.
What's your view of
why it is taking longer
and what we might expect to
see in the next few months
when we might be able to
vaccinate 12 and under?
And I am also curious, I've had a very
US specific view on that.
What are other countries doing
on the vaccination of younger people?
- So, first I think it's, again,
worth looking at how
astonishing the achievement
of pediatric vaccination has been.
I mean, if you look, actually,
back over the last century,
the biggest public health intervention,
along with clean water, that's
happened in human history is
actually pediatric vaccination.
I mean, it's astonishing
what pediatric vaccination
has been able to accomplish.
And we often forget that
because we just don't see mumps
and measles and rubella
and all of these conditions
any longer.
I mean, even pneumococcal pneumonia,
and meningococcal meningitis,
because these vaccines
have been so effective.
And so one, I think it's
worth reminding ourselves
that when we do get a
pediatric vaccine approved,
people should really look
to vaccinate children.
It's one of the most successful
public health interventions
that we've ever had.
Now, in terms of usually
how vaccines are developed
and including drugs, as
well, is we step down
through the age groups,
because we want to ensure
that there's a good safety profile.
Because children's immune systems,
you, of course, want to ensure
that you're not gonna have
any adverse consequences.
And so I think that's what's
being systematically done.
Usually, historically, what you do is
you get down to 11 year
olds, then 2 to 10 year olds,
and then under two years old.
And again, it's worth
remembering that most children
in the world get a lot of vaccines
when they're two months of age.
That's actually when we start vaccinating.
So we'll see how the data
develops on that front.
But my guess is over time,
we'll be getting down
in those younger and younger age groups.
I think many countries
around the world are similar
to the US now, at the 12 plus age range.
And then I think over the coming months,
we'll be able to get into
the pediatric age range
and then younger as well.
- And does it change depending on what,
I'm assuming there's
certain safety profiles,
you have to test the vaccine
in a certain scale normally,
but when you're in something
of a public health emergency
like this, do they change the rules
or do they just try to
run the trials faster?
How do they expedite things?
- Well first, I would say this vaccine,
these vaccines have the
biggest safety databases
of any vaccines, right now.
We have billions of doses, and
so the denominators here are
remarkable to look at any adverse event.
And while I think that
understandably there is
news media pick up whenever
there is any sort of event,
it's important to recognize
that in most cases,
these are astonishingly
rare and you have more risk
getting in your car in
the morning than you do
of any of these very rare
adverse events for vaccines.
And it's very hard as you
know, for the human mind
to assess risks, but I think
one of the useful things
to do is compare it to
the other risks you take
every single day, living your life,
and you see that these risks
are actually quite small.
The way the clinical
trials are, they're using
pretty standard clinical trials.
And I would say my own
experience in vaccines,
these numbers are very
large that they're using.
I mean, most of the databases here
in the clinical studies are
50,000 to 100,000 plus patients.
Those are very robust databases
to identify significant safety signals,
including in children.
So I would feel very
confident that the regulators
and the companies are
doing the right thing here.
- Yeah.
And, on that last point about
stack ranking the things
that are dangerous in life,
until we have a vaccine
for younger kids, at least here in the US,
we've heard stories now
that school is starting up,
you know, pretty scary stories of 10, 20%
of kindergarteners not showing up,
because parents are afraid
of the Delta variant.
And it is scary.
I have one of my oldest
got vaccinated, he's 12,
but my other two are not vaccinated.
So I definitely feel that,
but at the same time,
just my own curiosity,
I started looking up
hospitalizations and deaths,
and it does not, even the
Delta variant does not seem
dramatically different.
I might be wrong or maybe the
data hasn't fully come in yet,
with the flu.
And both of them are actually less likely
to kill a young person to your point
than a car or a swimming pool.
So, you know, for those of you in the...
what would be your advice to a parent
who's scared right now,
especially if they can't
get their kids vaccinated?
- Yeah, I think, again,
when you look at the data,
it would suggest that
especially in younger children,
that the risk here is very small.
I mean, even infected children,
despite the one-off news media
reports that you're hearing,
you know, you're seeing very
low rates of hospitalization
or severe disease.
And my guess is it's probably even better
than we see in the data
because the denominator
of number of children or adults
who are asymptomatically infected
or not captured is quite significant.
And there've been very good models
that have been produced
by different economists
and epidemiologists that
would suggest 5, 10,
maybe more fold under-counting
of the denominator,
which means that the actual
rate of hospitalization,
rate of severe disease,
rate of death is even lower
than what we might think otherwise.
So, you know, I would,
if the school is open and the school has
appropriate precautions,
I think the damage
we could be doing to
children by not ensuring
that they're continuing to
have their social development,
their educational development,
that's something we've
got to factor in too.
I mean, one of the things that I think,
I'm sure you're also
concerned about globally,
the loss of years of education
and the impact that will
have on the longterm mental
and social wellbeing for these generations
of children is just substantial,
and should be counted, right?
And counted and considered
whenever we think about
school lockdowns and school closures.
- Yeah, couldn't agree more, but it is,
it's gonna be interesting
how this plays out.
Well, thank you for
indulging me and all of us.
And, you know, I actually give
credit to Raina Rustenburg.
They asked a couple of questions
that I paraphrased a little bit.
So I want to make sure that
that YouTube viewer gets
proper credit for the questions.
But I do want to shift a little bit.
You know, I could talk for
hours about the vaccine
and how all of this might evolve,
but I also want to be
forward-looking post pandemic,
or maybe it's related to the pandemic.
I mean, you're running one of the largest
pharmaceutical companies in the world.
What are you excited about?
Where is medicine going?
I think medicine, a lot of
people compare education
to medicine and they're like,
"Look what medicine has
done in the last 50 years"
and education, there's a
lot of good in education,
but it looks like it's fairly similar
to the way it was 50 years ago
or a hundred years ago.
Hopefully some of that
will change for the better,
but what do you think
medicine is going to look like
if we fast forward 5
years, 10 years, 20 years?
- Yeah, it's interesting.
I mean, right now we're undergoing,
really a substantial
Renaissance in how we think
about therapeutics in medicine.
I mean, go again back in history,
it was really in the early 1900s
we began to think about medicine
as being able to impact the human body.
Before then we had much
less sophisticated views
on how to impact health.
We started with chemicals, so chemistry,
small molecule chemicals
that would interact
with proteins to try to
get a therapeutic effect.
Around the 1970s, 1980s,
we moved into the world
of producing large molecules,
so proteins to impact proteins
or proteins to bind other proteins
or proteins to bind
other things in the body.
That's called biologics.
We had small molecules and biologics.
And then there wasn't another revolution
until pretty recently,
where now there's been
an explosion of a few
different technologies.
Some of them, we work on.
Gene therapies, which allow us to edit
the genome of patients to really correct
for inherited abnormalities.
You have cell therapies
which are taking cells
out of the body, reprogramming them,
using technologies like
you've heard of, like CRISPR
that then reprogram the cells,
put them back in the body.
We have RNA and maybe
everybody knows about mRNA,
the other revolution that's happened
that was years in the making,
going back to work done
in the 1970s and 1980s,
is to understand how
RNA modulates other RNA,
and there's technologies called
antisense oligonucleotides
or silencing RNAs,
which can be used as therapeutics.
And those are now
getting approved as well,
so we're using RNA as therapeutics.
These are very small strands of RNA.
Now all of these areas
are opening up whole new,
all of these technologies, I should say,
they're opening up whole
new fields of medicine
where we can treat diseases
that we haven't been able
to treat in the past.
When you think about
the rough numbers here,
we can treat about 700 of
the roughly 8,000 to 10,000
diseases that are in
the various compendium.
So there's a lot of opportunity for us
to improve human health,
and these technologies are
helping us do that.
The other big revolution
now is data science and AI,
which I'm sure you've talked about.
I know it's impacting education,
impacting our industry,
as well.
So how can you use AI to find new drugs,
to develop drugs faster,
to produce those drugs more efficiently?
Probably many people would have seen
that Google recently
published the structures,
or DeepMind published the
structures of all proteins
that they've been able
to identify thus far
in the database.
Which is again, a massive
accomplishment done
through artificial intelligence.
- You know, it is mind boggling.
And I mean, I was thinking about asking,
but when will we see this?
But then I realized we
actually are seeing it.
It's happening behind the scenes.
I mean, even my wife,
who's a rheumatologist,
she's saying, the medications, the drugs
that she has access to even 20 years ago,
they were just maintaining the pain,
while now they can actually start to
provide therapies and treat.
If we go 10, 15 years in the
future, are there certain areas
that you're particularly hopeful about?
Or maybe you just want to jinx it yet?
But you know, I'm sure there's areas
that y'all are investing in that you think
that there's space for some innovation.
- Yeah, I think a few areas
that we have the opportunity,
I mean, the goal of course is to get to
a larger absolute efficacy gain.
And can you really get to maybe
even cures and remissions?
When you look at the whole
world of blood cancers,
it's astonishing, I mean,
the progress we're making,
and I'm hopeful that we can get to a world
with all of the efforts in our sector
and with academia and
government that maybe
nobody needs to die from a blood cancer,
given the pace of innovation
we're seeing there.
That's pretty remarkable.
When you look at certain rare diseases,
we already have a medicine that when given
to a child early enough,
can almost eliminate
what would have otherwise have been
a certainly terminal
disease for these children,
and that's with a single
injection of that gene therapy.
So I think in certain rare diseases,
you're going to see astonishing progress.
We're big believers in cardiovascular.
It's still, it's worth remembering,
the largest cause of death and disability
in the world is heart disease,
even more than any infection.
I haven't checked the numbers,
it may still have out done
COVID last year as well
in terms of overall death and disability.
So I think advances in
cardiovascular disease are
an opportunity to maybe
not have people die
from heart attacks or
subsequent heart attacks.
So those are areas of
tremendous opportunity,
cardiovascular disease, cancer, et cetera.
I mean, the places where we
have a lot of work to do is
still understanding better
the biology of the brain,
cognitive disorders,
psychiatric disorders,
neurodegenerative disorders.
The brain is a remarkable feat
of billions of years of evolution,
but still a lot of work
to do to understand
what's going on in the
diseases of the brain.
- Yeah, well, no,
it makes very hopeful
for where we're going.
And I know, I could talk
to you literally for hours,
hopefully we'll get a chance to do that,
but I just glanced at the clock.
I was like, "Oh, we're
almost out of time."
So, Vas, you know, I just
wanted to thank you incredibly.
I have to say it, you know,
and I'm not saying this
just because Novartis is
one of the major
supporters of Kahn Academy.
I think I would say this regardless,
but talking to you is
incredibly refreshing,
because there's a whole
CEO part of your job,
which, you know, the CEO part of my job,
which I try to do vaguely
competently is hard
and we are about 200 folks.
You were talking about a
hundred thousand plus employees.
And so you must be incredible at that,
but just speaking to you on science,
the fact how deep you can go
and that we can kind of nerd out together,
while you're also managing
a hundred thousand plus,
major pharmaceutical
entity that's giving drugs
to 800 million people,
it's kind mind blowing,
but at the same time heartening
to see how deep you can go.
So thank you for your
willingness to talk to me.
(Sal laughs)
- I appreciate it Sal.
I mean for anything, students out there.
I'm still a scientist at heart.
And I think, I hope I can prove
that you can be a scientist
and work in the business world,
but stay passionate about
science and medicine,
because what wakes me up every day is
those amazing findings that we have
that can transform human lives.
So always grateful to
be here and look forward
to the next conversation, Sal.
- Yeah, you know, amongst
like actors and stuff,
there's the notion of a double
threat or of a triple threat.
If you can act and sing
or act and sing and dance,
you know how to manage and nerd out.
Maybe you can actually sing and dance too.
We'll, talk about that next time.
- No, no.
My kids would tell you
I cannot act or sing
so they prefer me to
stick with being a CEO.
(both laugh)
- Excellent, excellent.
Well, thank you so much, Vas.
And say hi to your kids, who
I know are Kahn Academy users
and distributing Kahn Academy
stickers, which I appreciate.
- All right, take care.
- Well, thanks everyone for joining.
I hope you enjoyed that
conversation with Vas.
And I said it, I meant it,
it's actually incredibly
refreshing when you meet someone
who leads a multinational
organization like that,
but who can also really go deep
and clearly has a passion for what they do
and the impact they're
having on the planet.
So hopefully you found
that as inspiring as I did.
And I look forward to
seeing you all next time.
We are going to have a homeroom,
it's going to be with our
chief learning officer,
Kristen Dicerbo, gonna talk
to our head of content,
Adam Green, about all of the new content
and course refreshers on Khan Academy.
And I don't want to pick favorites,
because there's a lot of new content,
but we've been doing a big science push.
You know, that video I just talked about
around gene expression
and around evolution,
that's part of our science push.
So, keep a look out for that,
but you'll hear much more
about it on the Ed Talks
with Kristen Dicerbo and Adam tomorrow.
So with that, I will see y'all later.
Onward.